i can get through the day
i can take my daughter to the park here
and then i can sneak away to my favorite
part of the park
which is where the water is and you know
just kind of retool from the day and
re-center on my family i was diagnosed
with idiopathic hypersomnia when i was
19 years old it was a spanish teacher at
howard university
my first semester in school who noticed
that i was falling asleep in class there
was no one who said oh you're in your
late teens early twenties need to start
looking out for neurological disorders
we all experience spurts of more or less
sleep
many of us after missing a lot of rest
and feeling exhausted will sleep for
well more than the recommended seven or
eight hours
after that we feel more wakeful and
ready to go about our lives for people
with idiopathic hypersomnia or ih that's
not the case
someone diagnosed with idiopathic
hypersomnia sleeps for long periods of
time
say 11 hours within a 24 hour period but
never wakes up feeling refreshed i don't
remember what a good night's sleep even
feels like because people think they
know what it feels like to dream or be
really tired
people think they understand what we
deal with but they really have no clue
it's very frustrating for these patients
we give them this diagnosis that have no
meaning we know narcolepsy with
cataplexy which has a very clear cause
you know it's a deficit in orexin and so
forth but for all this other problem
idiopathic hypersomnia insomnia we know
this is complicated it's not a single
cause
number of years ago several of my
colleagues came up with a hypothesis
that potentially idiopathic hypersomnia
was being caused by an endogenous
substance that was turning on the
activity of gaba a receptors if you
produce something that activates those
receptors it could potentially be
sedating it might cause the sleepiness
of idiopathic hypersomnia and there's a
little bit of experimental evidence
suggesting that idiopathic hypersomnia
may have a circadian component to it as
well
people with idiopathic hypersomnia often
have a lot of difficulty waking up in
the morning they may be trying to wake
up at a time that their circadian rhythm
is telling their brain is still
nighttime what's hard for work is i'll
have a like dream like experience where
i've
woken up i've brushed my teeth i've had
a shower i've had breakfast put clothes
on gotten ready for work and then i wake
up and realize i've been sleep
the whole time and then now i'm running
late because
you know i thought i was awake but it
was all a hallucination like dream
if you don't sleep well
everything seems difficult to achieve a
typical issue is the ability
in
everyday's life to integrate a lot of
information
as we go about our daily lives we
receive a lot of information about our
environments maybe a new detour on the
road to work or a story in the news
that information causes our synapses the
sites where two nerve cells meet to grow
and exhibit learning in mice chirelli
showed that daily activities made their
synapses grow and add receptors to the
point that the synapses were saturated
restful sleep reduced the size and
strength of the synapses so that they
were primed for more learning after
waking up
without that rest the synapses remain
saturated and learning was more
difficult
now we think that really the reason why
the brain
needs to be disconnected
is indeed because
sleep does
synaptic homeostasis sleep allows
the weight
the strength of synapses
in the brain
to be renormalized you end up at the end
of the day having learned many things
but the price for this learning in
cellular in synaptic levels
is this increase in the strength which
is good again because it's a sign of
learning but in the long run is actually
not too sustainable one of the big
questions about sleep is is regulated by
two things
one is what's called a sleep homeostat
it's basically how much sleep debt sleep
need you have
but the second thing is that also
regulates sleep independently of the
sleep that is circulating rhythm right
now the only way to measure circuit in
rhythm is to keep people in a dark room
or at least constant dim light and
measure melatonin and it's very time
consuming and it's not very precise
now i'm very excited because i'm
developing some new technology where i'm
measuring some proteins thousands of
proteins 7500 and with these proteins we
can actually
predict uh the circuit and rhythm and
the sleep debt of patients so i think it
will really lead to a complete
redefinition of the diagnosis of people
who have idiopathic hypersomnia or
insomnia
in the next two to five years
researchers believe such a technique
could become a reality in diagnosing
sleep disorders in august the fda
approved the first treatment for ih a
drug that was already approved to treat
sleepiness and sudden loss of muscle
tone in people with narcolepsy
pinpointing the biological causes
diagnoses and treatments of poorly
understood sleep disorders could provide
hope for those with mysterious cases
having the diagnosis allows you some
options
and the more options that are created
that include rare disorders like ih the
more options people can have to live
fuller lives my daughter loves to climb
this tree but she's four so she has to
have a lot of support and the last time
we were here i started to have a spouse
getting really tired and she really
wanted
to sit up there i couldn't risk it
they're moments like that where you let
people down
but you know you're doing the right
thing
[Laughter]
[Music]
you